okay so I was going on about like the
offline first stuff earlier but there's
some where this has been happening for
years in Chrome apps
they've been providing like privileged
api's and sort of showing the open web
what it could be what it could be in
future and to talk about that a warm
welcome to Joe Marini all right hi
everybody all right
mic on you guys need me okay yeah all
right how's everyone feeling good I know
it's it's five o'clock I know you can
see I've used my extreme clout as a
Google speaker to secure the highly
sought after 5:00 p.m. slot I appreciate
you guys staying sticking around though
yeah I'm gonna be talking about Chrome
apps today a couple things first of all
I'm gonna try to speak slowly I am a New
Yorker that does not come easy to me
but I'll give it a shot second thing
please keep your arms and legs next to
you seat at all times till the
presentations come to a full and
complete stop and then we'll go and do
pinnacle and then we'll have some beers
just before I get started um how many
people have heard of chrome packaged
apps before today Wow everybody that's
fantastic all right how many people have
gone to the Chrome Web Store to get
content extensions apps whatever all
right just let everybody that's awesome
how about you guys in the live stream
yeah I'm imagining hands going up I
imagine it's a good thing awesome great
okay that's good this is me I'm
developer relations here chrome on the
chrome team for Chrome apps extensions
Chrome Web Store that's my contact info
please feel free to reach out and say hi
I am friendly I will respond usually
nicely please feel free to ask questions
I love getting questions so before I
begin I figured three slides in it's
always useful to do demos because I
think demos really resonate more than
just pictures on a slide so let me just
just quickly show you a couple demos
we've been at Chrome apps for a while
now this is the Economist app you may
have seen this so you can go to the
Chrome Web Store get this today it's
basically an app you notice right away
there's no you know URL bar there's no
back button right the up on the Mac here
there's an actual real menu bar I can
you know I can choose a story I can you
know keyboard through it got some nice
you know so nice performance there what
else let me show you something else here
is an Internet Relay Chat client that we
built using Chrome apps you know again
all html5 all JavaScript you guys are
probably wondering what this red light
down here is I was going to show this
later but I'm I'll show it now so Chrome
apps have the ability to work with the
hardware platform so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna jump over to this little
sub Network I have set up and I'm gonna
come over to this demo Philips makes
these light bulbs that you can actually
attach to the Internet in your house and
just like control them with your smart
phone and stuff so you can see that as
I'm you know changing the the dials here
my on my chrome app I'm actually
changing the kind of isn't that cool
native apps my friends in html5 and
JavaScript but I think probably one of
the best demos of all how many people
use sublime sublime text users awesome
yes watch this is really cool so I'm
gonna fire up sublime text alright
here's my sublime editor I'm gonna size
it down a little bit if I can use my
mouse there we go so there's sublime
right there you know movie foe just make
it a little bit smaller all right and
I'm gonna go over here whoops and I'm
gonna launch this whoops I'm gonna
launch this other app called carrot
which is a chrome app it was built by a
guy in his spare time and it's available
on the Chrome Web Store today and I've
got the two windows alright and I'm
gonna go ahead and add a directory why
not sure that one that looks great
okay which one's the chrome app which
one's the native app right
pretty good huh I mean this is html5 and
JavaScript it's you know it's it's just
fantastic stuff all right I mean I'm not
good in for the mouse to do the
three-card Monte otherwise I'd spin them
around and ask you to pick which one was
which but I'm actually not gonna do that
so all right let's go back to the all
right so of course the question you know
I mean that all looks great right and it
and it it performs well you can see that
we can do cool stuff but still you might
have this question you know like why
would I build you know why would I build
a chrome app why would I build a native
app when the web is so great and the web
is great we don't disagree
you know we're Google we love the web
web apps are print
stick there's lots of great webs web
apps out there today and they've been
around for a long time the problem is
that there comes a time when web apps
just really aren't all that great right
there comes a time when web apps are
decidedly not quite so awesome you know
offline is one of them we've all seen
this right you know you're trying to use
the the browser and you lose the
internet connection for some reason and
you get this nice white screen native
apps don't do this right native apps
don't I mean the Internet may come and
go but they're they're not doing this
white error screens for you games right
we all play games well not everybody but
I play games in the web web games are
great you have this full you know
keyboard this accurate pointing device
right but there are times when games are
just not as great right I mean wouldn't
it be awesome if you could give your
users the ability to use real Hardware
controllers and you know game sticks and
so on to play games but this is really
hard to do on the open web there's some
API is that you can use for your
accessing the game controller API but
not everybody supports it right and not
all of them work and so on but so it's
there are definitely some problems among
others but these are these are two of
the more important ones so Chrome apps
are intended to help solve this problem
they they run offline by default they're
basically designed by default to run
when there is no inter connection and
this isn't because all the resources are
packaged locally like a regular native
apps so offline is a very big pillar of
how Chrome apps work they also run
across all popular platforms
right out of the box by default it's
html5 and JavaScript you get Mac Windows
Linux chrome OS which is kind of like
Linux iOS and Android just out the box
okay html5 and JavaScript and I'll get
into that later I just showed a couple
of minutes ago that you have access to
the native hardware platform and the
native OS so you can do things like
access the USB port Bluetooth the
network right so they give you these
really great capabilities that the
native web does not yet have or if it
does have its kind of spotty they give
you a rich immersive engaging user
experience right I mean
who would have thought that someday
you'd be able to build you know
something like sublime text as a native
app out of html5 and JavaScript I mean
it's put the two side-by-side they look
really great you know next to each other
one's native ones html5 native but a
great experience and whoops and finally
you know one of the great things about
the web is that you get this
distribution model where you update your
code on the server and then people just
get the updated app right and that's all
great so the way that we address this in
Chrome apps is the Chrome Web Store
handles distribution
it handles updates so you write your app
right you put it in the store people
download it they're using it they're all
loving life
you ship an update right and then we use
the same update mechanism that the
Google servers use and chrome uses so
every whatever four or five hours right
the runtime is pinging the server saying
hey is there a new version hey is there
new version if there is the user gets
the updated version everything's great
right so that's these are these are the
kinds of issues that Chrome apps are
intended to are intended to address all
right
now I'm assuming that many of you
probably have existing web apps and
there are some differences when you're
building native chrome apps using web
technologies that you need to be aware
of it I'll cover some of that so let me
just begin first let's talk a little
about offline I'm gonna go through each
one of these in a little bit more depth
so let's talk about for a second what
offline really means because offline
means different things yes there's I
have no connection right the the network
cord was ripped out or I'm in someplace
like the desert or an airplane or
whatever and I just don't have an
internet connection that's one form of
offline but there's another form of
offline which is crappy offline right
maybe you're in a cafe and you forgot to
tip the barista and now the Wi-Fi is
mysteriously not working you know maybe
you work with Jake in the UK Google
office and you go to the bathroom and
there's no internet right maybe you're
in a super oversubscribed awesome
conference and the Wi-Fi is really busy
in the room right so these are all kinds
of situations and edge cases where
offline really matters and again think
back to using sublime right you're
sitting typing along right you're the
internet goes out someone doesn't care
it's it's not like it's getting its UI
from the wood from the from the internet
and updating it in real time it's just
you just keep right on working
and that's because all those resources
are stored locally they're packaged up
in a package rather you don't to
generate UI on the fly you don't have
some PHP script writing out HTML so the
so native apps had this really great
advantage in that regard where they just
recover from this
these recover from this natively so in
chrome apps all your resources are
packaged up locally and your app can be
launched any time now what this means is
you have to plan for having a great
offline experience right not everybody
you know things about this stuff and you
know the question of course comes up and
what about Service Worker what about app
cache you know yes serviceworker I agree
it solves a lot of these problems
there are things where serviceworker is
great for but think it's not just a nuts
to technology problem right it's a user
behavior problem we've spent the last 20
years teaching users that browsers don't
work when they're offline so even if we
had perfect app cache and serviceworker
tomorrow you'd still have to overcome
right this user inertia of I don't open
my browser because why would I right so
yeah there's so there's all these these
issues so to plan for a great offline
experience there's certain things you
have to do first you have to factor your
app in order to work offline so take the
HTML separate from the JavaScript and so
on it's only as a good idea to abstract
the app a little bit so that it's
talking to a data layer right this thing
about how sublime is working right
you're working on your code right it's
simply working on the data and then the
data layer is handling the part of
talking to the cloud or talking to local
storage or whatever it is right so if
you can make that abstraction things get
a lot easier you have to think a little
bit about what your apps offline
features are going to be and yes some
applications just don't work very well
when they're offline but that doesn't
mean they're useless right think about
an app like like Skype right Skype 95%
of the value of Skype is only there when
I have a connection right but when I
don't have a connection I shouldn't be
like hosed I should at least be able to
manage my contact list I should at least
be able to see my call history right so
there's still some value there so these
are the kinds of things you have to
think about like what kinds of features
does it make sense for my app to have
when it's offline we do since it's since
its Chrome and since its html5 you do
have access to things like the Navigator
online property I agree with Jake it's
not perfect it's better than
thing the good news is that most users
don't plug their network cables into
soil right I mean I've only done it
twice and once was my accident
right so I mean it it's not not most
people don't do that they actually do
plug into the wall they use the Wi-Fi so
it's it's better than nothing and we
give you lots of ways to store data now
there's a couple things that we that we
don't do we don't give you window dot
local storage because it's synchronous
and that blocks the you X thread so we
can't have the user sitting there
twiddling their thumbs while you're
moving megabytes of data back and forth
right so we try to fix that by giving
you a synchronous versions of
synchronous API is that would ordinarily
be in the web so for example we don't
support synchronous xhr right who does
these days why would you do that
so you we give you a synchro's versions
and chrome storage local is our
asynchronous version of window dot local
storage but you can use indexdb you can
use the html5 file system api right
there's there's lots of different ways
to store data and the the reason for
this the reason why this works is
because if you look at the way chrome
apps are structured you basically build
them the way that you would normally
build your web app you have your HTML
right you've got your JavaScript you've
got the other assets that make up your
application and then all we ask you to
do is put a little infrastructure around
that right there's a manifest file that
you write that defines what the app is
and does what its name is what its
description is what permissions it has
where the entry points are that kind of
stuff right then there's a file that you
get to define I've called it main js'
you can call whatever you want you
specify this in the manifest and that's
the file that spent that that takes care
of the entry points into your app so
there's an event for example hey my app
got launched hey might have got
restarted a cloud message came in and
alarm went off right so this is where
you handle those kinds of events and
that's all gets that's what is all
wrapped up into a zip file so all of
that gets packaged up into a zip that
goes up to the Chrome Web Store and then
you're in business you know we spend an
hour
you know scanning your zip file making
sure you know you're not trying to like
I don't know steal people's email
addresses or whatever right we do a
whole bunch of security scans then
you're published all right we don't
review your app we don't do any of that
you know in-depth stuff we just your
you're good to go
so to take an example right here's the
chrome storage API so you can see that
normally if I had a uniform and I want
to save some data in the form I would
get the value out of some text area and
then the the chrome that storage API
version of this of this function simply
takes of an object with properties in it
and it's asynchronous so there's a
callback function for when it completes
if you care about it great if not it
goes on its very way and your app is
good to go okay so very high very heavy
emphasis on asynchronous stuff in
addition to being offline by default we
are cross-platform by default and I
talked about this a few seconds ago if
you think back to what you hast had to
do to build native apps right like a
long time ago if you wanted to build a
native rich native experience and I've
talked about a long time ago I mean I
know many of you were not born like but
I'm talking about the sine period but
there was a time when all you did was
target basically Windows right you built
a native app for Windows if you really
cared about the 10% of people didn't
have Windows you built a Mac version
right and that was that was native apps
like some time ago now contrast that
with today right today he still got
Windows but you have multiple versions
of Windows all right you start at the
Mac but there's multiple versions of the
Mac right then there's iOS and there's
Android all right now there's got that
least great native platform mobile
platforms are coming up Linux Linux is
in the mix what does a bunch to have 20
25 million users right there's a lot of
people have to use this but of course
there's Chromebooks right four out of
the top five selling laptops on Amazon
right now our Chromebooks hard to
believe but it's true so you've got all
these rich platforms right that you'd
have to deliver a native experience for
and there's costs involved here just on
this screen alone there's what there's
Objective C C sharp right Java C++ all
kinds of native API is right there
different for each platform right and
then there's all the hidden costs that
developers never think about like
building installers building updaters
right long time ago I worked at
Macromedia on Dreamweaver and I was
tagged as the Installer guy you don't
ever want to be tagged as the Installer
guy you will never get away from being
the Installer guy every question comes
to you about the Installer but these are
the kinds of things that Chrome apps get
you away from we handle the installation
we handle the up
we handled the cross-platform stuff so
that's it's another great advantage of
Chrome apps in addition to being offline
cross-platform we have a very heavy
emphasis on being cloud enabled by
default and that's because users
increasingly expectance they expect that
their data is gonna be in the cloud make
sense it's gonna be synced and we give
you a bunch of features that let you
leverage this stuff so I talked a little
bit earlier about the chrome storage
local API there's also a sync version
you guys noticed that when you're using
Chrome you have all these bookmarks
you've got different versions of your
different computers and they all sync
across all your Chrome's right we just
give that to you we give you that
infrastructure so all you got to do is
call a few lines of JavaScript and your
data and preferences and properties get
synced across your application no
special work you have to do that's
that's for smaller data sets for large
data sets there's a sync version of the
html5 file system so you can store
megabytes of data and it's backed by
Drive now today it's backed by Drive
it's extensible so if somebody else
wants to build a syncing architecture
they can do it but out of the box it's
backed by Drive there's a cloud push
messaging API built into Chrome apps
this is one of the cool things about
Chrome apps let's suppose your app is
even running right the users got their
laptop open they're doing something but
they haven't launched your app yet right
the chrome runtime is running though and
it's listening so you can actually send
a cloud message through our servers to
the chrome runtime chrome will wake your
app up right tell it that I got a
message
which is really cool you can't do them
the open web today right there's no way
for a web app to wake the browser up and
be like hey go to this URL all right
that'd be scary right but Chrome apps
can do that chrome ask and listen to
cloud messages there's an identity API
who loves writing OAuth code loves it
yeah I don't either right we've got an
API that handles this so doing things
like authenticating users is easy in
Chrome apps we have one API function
that's specific to Google services and
because you're signed game when you're
using Chrome apps basically happens as
you call this function you say I want to
see who the user is you get the token
back and then off you go there's also a
function that you call for third-party
services so if you want to authenticate
using I don't know Twitter or whatever
right there's a way to do that so just
give you an idea what this looks like
for the sync file system this the first
example shows how to use the
synchronize file system to sync data the
first line basically says set the
conflict resolution policy these are
things you have to think about right
data conflicts and you have a choice you
can say you know what I want the last
right to win or you can say you know
what I'll just handle it don't worry
about it
but then once you have that you just
simply call request file system like you
ordinarily would on any other html5 file
system API you get an FS object back and
then you're working with the file
systems like any other file system only
this one is synced right just for you
just taken care of for identity the two
api's I talked about the first one get
off token that's what the Google
services so if I'm signed aim with my
you know my gmail account whatever I
just call this function and I can
specify whether I want to be interactive
or not and then there's a callback
function right there's that
asynchronicity again the second version
the launch web off flow that's the third
party version right and and so because
what happens in olaf normally is you
have this redirect URL where the the
third party service calls back to that
this is an app so there's no like
webpage to do this we have this function
right here there's a callback function
that takes the redirect URL so when that
gets called all you do is get the token
and you're off and running you're signed
in right pretty straightforward I
haven't done time good right so I talked
a little about immersive user experience
chrome apps obviously live outside the
browser they can have richer interfaces
experiences this of course means that
your app is going to be responsible for
things that it was not responsible for
in the past and you know it's important
to remember that users they just have
different expectations of apps versus
websites they expect deeper platform
integration they expect better
performance from a native app even
though users want great performance from
web apps I don't want Colt to come
running up here like smack me in the
head but yeah they expect great
performance from web apps but users
basically understand I click a button
it's got to go to the server and get the
content and come back native apps they
don't have the expectation right they no
one expects like a text editor to go off
to the web and get content and come back
they want responsiveness so they expect
that because users just aren't in a
browser frame of mind when they're using
an app right they're just not thinking
in that mindset they're just they're
using an app and they expect it to work
flawlessly and quickly so we give you
some API as to help out with this a lot
so
first we give you a full windowing API
to manage your apps windows so you can
do things like see how big the screen is
see how many screens there are you can
you know do things like figure out where
to put initial windows you need to
remember this is an important thing is
an example of something that's subtle
but users expect this in the past the
browser basically said here's your
window and here's where you are and
here's how big it is right and your web
app was like I guess where my window is
well apps don't work like that right
imagine how frustrating would be if
every time you close sublime you you
open sublime to get it right where it is
you get the window size you close it it
comes back up again it's this big right
that would drive you nuts wouldn't it
well it's gonna drive chrome app users
nuts too so you have to remember things
like remembering window location
remembering size now the good news is
we'll do that automatically for you if
you give your windows IDs so it's not a
whole lot of work involved on your end
but examples of things that people
expect you can control whether the OS
title bar is shown you don't like the
title bar don't show it make your own
its HTML and then what we do is we give
you this little WebKit app region
whatever you specify that the drag
property on whatever you want to be the
dragger and then that's it that's your
title bar or whatever other drag regions
so full control we give you a context
menus API users had this annoying habit
a right-click they want something happen
right and so we give you this native API
to do this what's cool about this though
is if the context menus API works
outside the app so you can specify that
somebody write clicks on your app icon
in the launcher you can specify the
content fields in there so it's pretty
cool nice nice native integration
there's an alarms API there's an API for
getting the media galleries on the
user's computer right now all of this is
obviously behind permissions right but
you can do things like get photos get
movies get music right there's just
built-in ways to do this you get a file
system just like you'd expect any other
file system so the user says yep you can
have access to my photos right there you
go
there's a URL handlers API right so you
can specify that your app as long as you
own the URL right you can specify that
your app is the handler for a specific
URL scheme right now you have to own the
URL your app can't say oh yes I handle
Gmail URLs right no it's got to be
you've got to prove ownership of the URL
or the pattern at least and you do that
in the Google Webmaster Tools and your
app is able to respond intent like two
users clicking on you know URLs in in
emails for example so we give you really
great ways of making an immersive user
experience alright let's talk a little
bit about integrating with the OS I
showed this a little bit earlier so
Chrome apps have access to the native
hardware platform you get access to the
USB port bluetooth right the network you
can go out discover devices obviously
this has privacy and security issues it
sure would be crazy if I was able to
control this light bulb from my friend's
house right or whatever so again this is
paramount once you start accessing
things on the user's Hardware and so on
privacy and security become really
really important so it's important to be
clear to the user about when you're
using resources on their system now in
some cases you don't have a choice right
but if you turn on the you turn on the
camera and the little light comes on
right you don't have any control over
that but in other cases where you're
using the files or storing large amounts
of data just be clear to the user about
what you're doing right it's really
important and of course when you're done
you got to release this stuff because
it's shared by the system share gotta
share alright I'm five minutes okay
let's talk a little about application
security and CSP who's heard of CSP
everyone's heard of it that's great I
won't go deep into it I'll included the
link in the presentation so you can read
more about it basically there's certain
content security policy defaults that
apps set and that you can't override so
for example you can't use things like
eval in your Chrome apps you can't use
things like new function all your
JavaScript code has to be in separate
dot J's files and the reason is because
if somebody's you know puts a script tag
in the head of your page and we have no
idea how it got there did you put it
there they put it there we don't know
right so it's got to be in a separate
file you can't do things like inline
event handlers you got to do things the
new school add event listener way
iframes you can use iframes
but there's sandbox into their own
origin in the page so you can post
message into and out of an iframe
but the iframe can't get into the parent
page and start calling chrome api's
again that would be bad and
you've got to declare where your content
comes from if it's not local so if you
think back to that Economist app I was
showing all those images one of the
things you can't do in a chrome app is
just simply say image tag path to random
image on web right because you have to
declare local content now that's a
pretty common pattern so we've actually
written a library that handles us for
you it'll go out to the web xhr stuff
down locally and then you use blob URLs
or object URLs to refer to them in the
app paul lewis actually wrote that it's
a really great library of course you
might really want to do that stuff right
but wait a second I really want to do
that stuff I really wanna use eval got
templating library we do provide ways to
get around some of these limitations or
security measures that we've put in so
first we have a webview component that
you can embed inside your apps it's
actually it's it's the rendering engine
of Chrome it's not Chrome itself there's
no extensions that come in right but
it's the it's the actual rendering
surface of Chrome so what you're
basically doing is embedding chrome
inside of Chrome and it gets a little
inception like at that point but it
actually works it's really cool so you
could use things like you can do things
like embed web content and again you can
do the post messaging they can
communicate with each other which is
great you can execute script in the
webview which is great for actually
remote resources I talked about this
it's that xhr library that Paul route
for tempering libraries this is where
things get a little interesting you know
because the if they're using eval a new
function there's a couple of things you
can do here one you can pre compile your
templates right handlebars this is for
example or there's a way for getting
around this stuff you can declare a page
in your application and it doesn't have
to be visible as a sandboxed page and
then what happens is all that bad stuff
is now okay again you can do things like
eval a new function but that page is
kept separate right it doesn't have
access to the chrome API is you can't do
things like you know call the chrome
stuff in your application and you use
post message back and forth so you could
put the template library in that page
send a message have it do all that stuff
it sends the results back to you and so
then everything is all nice and safe and
isolated all right mobile it's all about
mobile really quick I've got a couple
minutes left so we are working to bring
chrome apps to mobile devices via the
Cordova project who's heard of Cordova
all right have you ever spent everybody
okay so
Apache Cordova basically is the open
source version of PhoneGap when when
adobe acquired PhoneGap they open-source
the code kinda like we have chromium to
chrome right they've got Cordova to
PhoneGap basically that's basically what
it is so we're working to bring a set of
key api's over from the the chrome API
set to mobile where it makes sense we've
got about six or seven that we've we've
worked out so far we think probably by
early January we'll have a beta issue
for you guys to work with and it'll be
great you guys will be able to write one
codebase you'll get mobile apps and and
local apps the workflow is pretty
straightforward you install the toolset
you can import an existing chrome app or
start from scratch it's up to you you
know you iterate over your code your
debug and then when you're ready to ship
it goes into the native app store
alright because these are native apps
they don't go in the Chrome Web Store so
for iOS goes to the App Store right for
Android it goes to play right so it's
not that's not Chrome Web Store is only
for the desktop version so that's that's
a key difference so these are the AP is
that we're going to support initially a
lot of these are are pretty well baked
already on Android we're working to
bring some of them to iOS actually this
may be a little bit outdated I think we
might actually have notifications now
but this is the initial API so that
we're working on and it's actually it's
a thing of beauty let me show you my bit
remember that Internet Relay Chat client
I showed you a few minutes ago let me
just do this I'm gonna bring this up
right here I'm gonna tab over ok so
there it is that's the IRC client let me
bring up the other one so you guys can
see you can see it side by side right
there's that one all right there's the
UI there's the mobile version running on
my Android device same codebase html5
JavaScript right CR see when I book my
android and my desktop oh my god code
base yes female audience member same
codebase same stuff all right
so if that's got you interested if this
is exciting
if you think that Chrome apps might be
something might want to work on these
are the URLs you need to look for we've
got our github repo the Chrome App
samples all the API is that that are in
the platform have a corresponding sample
developer.chrome.com/apps is where you
go to learn about all this stuff we
document all the API is there and it
looks like I'm about seven seconds early
so thank you very much